creo que no porque el congreso la mesa
directiva del Congreso
rechazó una cuestión de confianza
planteada por el Primer Ministro Y eso
generó el temor de que la nueva primera
ministra planteara una segunda cuestión
una cuestión de confianza y la
Constitución Establece que el rechazo de
cuestión de confianza a dos primeros
ministros habilita la disolución el
congreso El Ejecutivo en un discurso del
presidente
interpretó que esa ese rechazo de plano
por la mesa directiva que no es una
desaprobación sino una negativa
tramitarlo era equivalía una
desaprobación con lo cual la nueva
primera ministra si era si se le
rechazaba la cuestión de confianza que
tiene que plantear por mandato
constitucional entonces la
disolución queda habilitada sin embargo
en la mañana de ayer apareció una
resolución Suprema en la cual el
presidente le acepta la renuncia al
Primer Ministro pero
no indicando que lo hace por ningún
rechazo de ecuación de confianza y no
por el pedido del Primer Ministro y no
indicando que lo hace por mandato
constitucional con lo cual el problema
Tendría que haber terminado sin embargo
en la tarde el congreso decide presentar
una demanda ante el tribunal
constitucional pidiéndole que declare
que la cuestión de confianza ha sido mal
realizada con lo cual reabre la
discusión creo que cuando cuando en la
mañana de ayer aparece la resolución
Suprema del presidente diciendo que
acepta la renuncia del Primer Ministro
sí sin mencionar en la cuestión de
confianza el incidente quedó cerrado
pero el congreso lo reabrió en la tarde
sí Y a propósito de que el congreso
demandará al presidente Castillo ante el
tribunal constitucional explíquenos que
puede ocurrir con esa demanda y cuáles
son los pasos a seguir
lo que puedo lo que tendría que ocurrir
es que el tribunal constitucional
declare improcedente la demanda porque
ya lo dijo en un anterior ocasión el
tribunal no
absule el tribunal lo que hace es cuando
hay una demanda competenciales acceder o
rechazar el pedido del demandante de que
se anule un acto de otro órgano del
Estado pero lo que está haciendo el
congreso es pedirle que declare que la
función de confianza que ya se ejerció
ha sido ha sido realizada contraria al
derecho al derecho nacional peruano pero
ese trámite ya terminó terminó con el
rechazo de plano por la mesa directiva y
con la resolución Suprema del presidente
en la cual no menciona la cuestión de
confianza entonces
técnicamente tendría que ser
improcedente porque equivale una
consulta El problema va a ser que el
tribunal ingrese a analizar y dar un
pronunciamiento y estaría reabriendo el
tema Sí y hoy el poder judicial convocó
a una reunión entre el presidente
castillo y el presidente del Congreso
José Williams precisamente para intentar
bajar estas tensiones sin embargo
ninguno de los dos asistió que señal
envía esto a la polarización política
del país
creo que envío una señal muy clara que
tanto el presidente como el el del
Congreso como del de la República con el
presidente del Congreso interpretan
posiciones políticas simplemente
confrontacionales en la cual pasa algo
muy muy curioso muy notable realmente
notable los dos intentan generar la
apariencia de que quieren hacer que
pierde el cargo uno el congreso los
congresistas y otro el presidente pero
ninguno activen los mecanismos
pertinentes para eso el presidente de la
república puede ser destituido por el
congreso y el congreso inicia un juicio
político previsto en los artículos 99
siendo la Constitución por infracciones
constitucionales que el presidente
es muy probable que haya cometido varias
sin embargo el congreso se niega a
realizar ese procedimiento